My forehead before I booked an appointment.
Forehead after I still did not book an appointment.
I saw a 40 year old esthetician say
that this serum by Medik8
was literally going to put her out of business.
I could not have bought it quick enough.
It put epidermal growth factor in this
similar technology that they use when you go in office
only to pump up collagen here,
elastin here, density structure here.
But it also supports the cellular matrix,
which is basically like a spanks layer underneath our skin
to hold everything up. And taught this degrades as we age,
which is why we can see some loose,
saggy skin and some drooping.
In Korea, they heard
there's a massive wave of women
who don't want to get this done to their face.
So they put the no tox peptide in this,
which is a cetyl hexapeptide 8.
The peptide actually works underneath the skin and the muscles
to smooth them over and give a relaxed appearance.
So the skin on top smooths over and relaxes.
So we're not freezing our face,
we are just relaxing.
Take it from someone who has used this for literally years,
it freaking works. Basically,
Medik8 just took my 60 step anti aging skin routine.
And so we're gonna give you professional technology in one serum.
But we're gonna make it so freaking affordable.
And we're just gonna pray to god that it doesn't sell out.
This is their newest release and If it's even still in stock,
I'm gonna put the link right there.
But if you don't see that orange shopping cart,
it just means it was sold out.